how about that new segment boys the name
game you guys are for sure first this is
Andrew stone it's big Andrew oh we've
got it was something hid from him before
every I think so
yo what up I got one for the new hitter
the name game who can name more
nocturnal animals let me know name gang
buzz you go I go okay all right so we
can no you know what y'all see him okay
well he's you know that I was go back
and forth okay alright Batman that's a
human bat that works okay now Liz good
worm moles moles what moles mo le i'm or
okay [ __ ] okay okay okay keep going
in fact check out [ __ ] yeah and mine
right now Derek if you're responsible
for writing it down Derek has the
computer from he's writing it was fun
yeah that's very change my turn
nighttime animal I'm gonna go with a
trustee out of my deal oh I don't know
if they are a nighttime animal do they
stay up at night see just Google
armadillo images see if there's any
pictures of just darkness around them in
their eyes lit up
alright then I'll go while they're
looking I'm gonna say a shark animal bro
they can't stop they can't stop they
will stop all night bro are they really
nice that's how they breathe do sharks
get rest at night we Google that they're
swimming non-stop so that's not turtle
suck do sharks sleep Derek's checking
right now sharks do not sleep when says
have two active restful so they go you
know I'm saying wow could just type in
nocturnal animals guys we didn't want to
see them all yeah well you have to bring
it I guess whatever
[Laughter]
is still running on [ __ ] Netscape
okay I'll go with a nocturnal animal and
I'm gonna treat you guys to a very
special animal right now and this
wonderful animal that a lot of people
aren't even from miliar with is called a
lightning bug is its street name all
right coming into this one Theo's mom
probably grills them up on the weekends
that little possum thank you dude they
are not tasty though it's all fat bro
and some of the some of the meat is just
brown fat yeah and you're like what is
this dude it's just me okay nocturnal
animal I'm gonna go with an animal that
a lot of people don't even really often
chat about or talk with other people
about because they're afraid
spider all spiders are nocturnal
I'll hit you with that burglar of the
rainforest that [ __ ] rat Greg who's
always get cars are like okay nocturnal
animal let me think about one that's
very nocturnal please do okay
an animal you'll see at night if you're
outside at night yes yep and you're say
you're wandering around and you think oh
what is that an animal and that animal
is no I'm not doing it up Derrick
Rottweilers at night
Derrick if you're not a spell Rottweiler
you just lost your urban card intrusion
horse dude [ __ ] come on to the whole
things he helped her out well I won't
sleep Rottweiler at night she cries a
lot at night and that's what I would
hear let's go to cat Derrick what do you
guys have nocturnal animals mmm izakaya
escort took that submission by the way
mmm
that would have actually that was made
it one Nick you got any I feel like we
did all right good what's the last thing
it to come up with that it's hard to
think about what animals are out there
any night coyotes nocturnal them little
[ __ ] meow
yeah they how do they really damn
hiya don't have that kind of money where
I have coyote problems okay this only
yeah you have to be like a brand-new
American Mexican person if coyote issues
or a wealthy [ __ ] person ever
- I like those kangaroos oh those ruse
but they sleep a lot I think you have a
maternal are they really you know what
is funny tunnels when I think about him
I do think about him like being up at
night
[Music]